we have to find the people they can
mobilize themselves it's impossible to
find two to encourage an active person
when you work with people who believe in
the same things they believe it's crazy
how quickly you can grow you choose
somebody to listen to and you choose
somebody to learn from you choose a
business partner can you choose a client
they gotta be as crazy and they gotta be
as as you that's how you get success
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message surround yourself
with greatness over to you Jack Ma how
do I a motive I incentive or x are
colleagues
you have to find the people became
mobilize themselves it's impossible to
find to to encourage an active person so
the people your high that people work
together they they have to be oh you
cannot we have a 65,000 in price now you
cannot high all of them that positive
but at least the people work with me my
management leadership several areas they
have to be positive
they have to know the incentive the
others because I cannot accept of
everybody and making sure the culture so
I think it would be very painful for me
to talk to my vice president and he need
to be incentivized and mobilized every
time right this won't work if he is not
if he does not know how to incentivize
or mobilize his people it's better I
don't think he will be the vice
president they should be a good engineer
good designer but not a good leader a
good leader should know how but not by
only money
most of people incentive lies or move on
not because you give them a lot of money
you give the respect trust appreciation
and correct heartful advice when it come
to my meetings internal meetings you
have you shocked because we we're not
like a lot of other Chinese company the
boss say and listen take notes and go
down we are like a war room we make
decision based on whose voice is louder
early days you know slider the talk and
then making sure everybody speak up so
this is also a way of mobile life and
incentives there are a lot of ways and
different people have a different way to
send incentives so for me building a
great team all starts with the mission
it's for you to have a clear mission of
what you want to try to do what do you
what are you in business to do what is
it the goal that you're trying to
accomplish and then bring you people on
board who love that mission and they
wake up motivated by the mission if you
have to wake up every day and remind
them of a financial incentive or remind
them of what you're doing every day they
can't carry some of that themselves that
may not be the best person have on your
team you need to love what you are all
about it's why and all of my job ads
when I'm posting to bring people on
board I always leave with a mission
here's what my company does way before
anything else about the job
responsibilities because I want people
to either love that job posting or
hate it if I'm hiring a videographer
it'd be I'm looking for a videographer
who believes in entrepreneurs and people
will then see a whole paragraph about
believe and what it means and they will
look at that and say this is a stupidest
thing I've ever seen
great do not apply we will not work well
together even if you have the best
skills at the job it won't work because
we are not aligned well but others will
look at that and say that is amazing
final is exactly what I'm thinking and
they self select in and what you've done
is now separated yourself to say here's
what I stand for here's how to tell the
difference between my company and all
the other people in my industry and it
allows you to be a magnet for the people
who believe the same things you believe
when you work with people who believe in
the same things you believe it's crazy
how quickly you can grow how amazing the
day-to-day work life experience is and
how much amazing work you can get done
what kind of results can come but if
you're spending some of your time
fighting with each other on what the
direction is gonna be for the company
and when you have somebody who's
underneath you who doesn't believe in
the mission and they're forcing
themselves to be there or they're there
just to collect a paycheck you're not
gonna get great stuff done I had a great
shot on Instagram live with a hardcore
YouTube fan Michael from chart your
trade he was asking about partnerships
and how do I know if it's the right
partnership or not and do we share the
same values and where are we aligned and
should we continue down this path and I
asked him why did you start your
business like what's the mission what
are you trying to accomplish and he said
he wants to try to end global poverty
through financial education great is
your business partner on board with that
plan yes great if your partners if your
team is on board with the plan then
everything else can be worked out the
actual execution whether you're gonna be
doing Facebook marketing or a blog or
going hardcore on Twitter or doing PR
like a lot of those things can be
figured out because you're both hitting
the same northstar if the North Star is
not the same then there's no point being
together there's no point being with
that business partner is no point hiring
that person onto your team you start
with the North Star and then everything
else falls into place I think the second
thing though about building a great team
is you just need to care if you want to
be a great leader you have to actually
we care about the people on your team
and that sounds obvious but a lot of
people don't and I think the way to show
care can be really different depending
your personality as an example for me I
am not the kind of guy who likes hanging
out I don't go to parties I don't go to
dinner I don't like just chilling and
spending time no it's not what I do and
so I look at this business trying to
dance also an example I'll tell all my
instructors I'm not gonna be your best
friend I'm not gonna be the guy who will
go hang out and grab drinks together
it's just not my style like if you need
that you expect that don't be a friend
they're insulted because it's just not
who I am with anybody I do I don't do
that with my other friends either but I
care for them more than most people in
their life and especially given how
little I know them compared to the
people around them so as an example I
have a new instructor in training here
at TBS think Christie who has Lyme
disease and I didn't know anything about
Lyme disease and I met with her for the
first time and she told me she had Lyme
disease and she's told the class so it's
not some random thing that nobody knows
about and so I got curious about what
she's trying to do where she's going
what's her path and she wants to create
eventually a holistic clinic where she
can try to solve these kinds of diseases
like Lyme disease and so for me I
actually care about the individual much
more than the business I understand that
this is Christy's long-term path this is
where she wants to go and will be
aligned for some time hopefully you know
as long as possible where we're running
the same path where she's part of TDS
and teaching and having an impact but at
some point it may mean she goes and
leaves and she goes and does her own
thing because that's ultimately where
she wants to go and I'm gonna push her
to do that I don't want people to stay
here when they could go off and do
something amazing the worst thing you
can do is tell me your dream this is for
anybody like the word is saying you do
around me anybody in my ecosystem or
environment is tell me what your dream
is because as soon as I know what your
dream is I'm thinking I'm working I'm
tweaking I'm I'm gonna be your
accountability partner to make sure that
you actually go off and do the things
that you need to do to accomplish your
dream and so for Christy with Lyme
disease now now Lyme disease is on my
radar
I've never heard of it before I didn't
know what it was but now I know about it
now I'm getting articles and content at
least once a week that then I'm sharing
with her and trying to help her you know
find some path we'll build her business
out and I care more about that than I
should we've had one meeting together
and that's how I show care you need to
figure out how you show care but if you
want to build a strong loyal dedicated
team that has to be a part of it you
have to care about the individual more
than you care about the business and
that may mean that ultimately they have
to leave the business and you're
cheering them on is they're exiting the
company and so I think those two things
one leaving with the mission you living
the mission daily and attracting people
who want to do the same thing who love
the goal that you have set for the
company and can bring their skill sets
knowledge heart and passion towards it
so you're getting their heart and not
just their brain and then it's showing
in whatever way you show it that you
care for your team that's how you become
a great leader that's how you build a
great business that's how you create a
great structure and system to allow you
to accomplish great things now I've got
a really special bonus clip for you but
before that my question of the day I
want to know what is your big inspiring
mission what is the thing that you
really want to try to accomplish share
it down in the comments below be excited
by the words that you are writing and
hey who knows maybe somebody reading
what you wrote could be the next
collaborator for your company so leave
it down below thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clip
let's pray so give me go
so when you choosing someone when you
choose somebody to listen to and you
choose somebody to learn from and you
choose a business partner you choose a
client they got to be as crazy and they
gotta be as as you that's how you get
success that's how you know you're gonna
be able to push that individual that's
how you know that relationship is gonna
last you know people talk about in
business or think oh you got to find a
balance you got to find that person you
know if you're one way you got to find a
person that's the other way you know
there's that's pulling you away from how
you want to do things and how if you're
intense the next person I want is to be
as super intense super intense now those
people around you they got to be smarter
than you are right but you don't want to
surround yourself with people that if
you're the smartest person in the room
you need to get more people in the room
sure okay you should not walk into the
room and ever be the smartest person in
there like the people around you have to
be much smarter or at least in certain
things you may have an expertise in one
thing with that other individual better
have an expertise that's beyond yours in
something and something else like but
from the my standpoint you know MJ was
just as as I was Kobe just as as I was
from him up from being the best okay I
wanted to be the best at what I do they
wanted to be the best at what they do
all right there was an attraction it's
an attraction and those are the people
that allow you to push them and allow
them to they understand they want to get
they want to get better you know they
don't need to be motivated okay they're
like you tell them hey we're interesting
they're not they're not hiring you to
come motivate me nobody wanted as bad as
the best of the best
already wanted more than anybody else
there's a reason they're the best you
know we we talked about this earlier at
lunch they're the ones that are show up
to practice early okay they're the ones
taking the extra shots they're the ones
doing the wind sprints at the end
they're the ones you know getting
treatment taking care of the body
they're showing up they're showing up on
off days you're juicing you're sending
the guys home you're saying you gotta go
gotta go home you got a little eat you
got it you got to tell them to leave you
don't have to tell them to show up yeah
I tell them to leave that
that that's enough you know you have
people in your office you look at it you
know how many employees do you have now
we got forty two hundred eighteen forty
two hundred agents okay out forty two
hundred agents okay if you put them all
in all in the room okay and you were
able to put them all in one shop
together alright and say your hours were
9:00 to 5:00 okay
you've got 4,200 people in here from
night from 9:00 to 5:00 o'clock from
five o'clock after five o'clock may have
five hundred after seven o'clock you may
have 200 after nine o'clock you may have
five and then guess what at the end of
the day there's gonna be one light left
on maybe to yours and somebody else's
that person says as you are but you can
count on that you can count on that
individual let's answer the question
okay yeah the question is what keeps us
together thank you for staying focused
okay here's the thing I'm very I'm very
strong and believing and the group that
you keep around you is a representation
of who you are
we keep a solid group around us and our
group carries a responsibility of not
being funny well don't judge spank by
this it's making told you judge him by
coming what should I judge him on judge
Bank let's have a half-hour special
Comedy Central
[Applause]
we are literally have grown together and
I think when you get to see your crew
really become successful within their
own rights and it can branch out with
new things as a representation of who
you guys are as a unit and we look back
and we look at the road and that circle
that we have
nobody's pop that bubble we don't allow
other people to come into it because we
have such a unique bond and a way that
we move and if somebody else comes into
it also that we did raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
we believe that people with passion and
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
Europe it's something to me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely infested hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten Rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details